cicadas bikinis on a killing spree we
need to get all those Meadows to a safe
house before cicada finds this guy's
dead we should ever sit
that's to kill us I say we kill them
first know what your name won't be like
Maura
your there's a killer still at large in
our city that man hurt your child if
you're not careful that anger will
consume you the same way it can seem to
him no it's mine
he never stops chili I thought my future
would be just right
you're not gonna watch anybody else be
broken by this mania let's go get up
goodbye fast you too would fast enough
so let's let's worry about soon when
you're about okay
oh no you're staying put
yeah seriously got your ass kicked not
good I can't feel my legs
[Music]
I can't feel my legs
either trust me or you don't there's no
in between fine I don't trust you but
I'm willing to give you the chance to
change my mind well that might take some
time in time as you may recall is not on
my side
and answer minutes seconds seconds
there's very few of them left
[Music]
I want to believe that there is good
inside of you somewhere thought
[Music]
let me prove there is
okay
what's next the flash on this Tuesday at
8/7 central on the CW hey everybody its
charlie we got brand new flash footage
to break down Nora is getting the Barry
Zoom treatment from way back in season 2
if you couldn't tell like it's a direct
reference to zoom breaking Barry's spine
during season 2 episode 6 guys I can't
feel my legs so if you couldn't tell
this is all playing into the art that
they set up with reverse flash can bad
people turned good because of what
Norfolk says so a whole bunch of Easter
eggs in this let's break it down there's
a new round of that flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite flash
moment on the video uh name a new winner
at the end of this so the official
description reads cicada severely
injures Nora so that's like the big WTF
of the episode amongst probably many
others is this during a battle with
cicada nor is severely injured due to
cicadas dampening powers though the
extra WTF spin on the Barry entry from
back in season two is that Nora's speed
healing isn't working leaving Barry and
iris scared for their daughters future
of said about his injured child the
flash is filled with rage and confront
cicada in a brutal battle like that
footage that you see of them brawling
inside that pool hall then Barry like
just winding up in the biggest punch
that he's ever probably tried to make
meanwhile as part of the big metahuman
cure story line that says killer frost
keeps interfering with Caitlin's work on
the cure so very clearly she's not on
board with them making a cure for all
metahumans but of course Cisco wants to
be stupid thinking this is gonna make
people's lives better really I think the
smarter thing for them to do would be to
try and get rid of metahuman technology
because they referenced something
interesting when they were talking about
how that special fast and furious
Batmobile looking car was last week with
a metahuman tech they called it polluted
dark matter which is why it was messing
with Barry's abilities to phase so maybe
it would be smarter to go after that
kind of dark matter and tried and get
rid of that rather than try and get rid
of metahumans that want to get rid of
their powers usually when you find a
metahuman that doesn't like their powers
this is a very x-men Marvel type of
story a mutant that has an ability that
just figures them in some real awful way
that makes it hard for them to just live
a normal life or you people like rogue
they just can't touch people or else
they'll potentially kill them if there
normal person or SAP their powers at
their another mutant early prediction
for the North storyline is that even
though her healing powers have been
turned off within the next couple of
episodes she'll be back to normal
because when Barry lost his ability to
walk it was basically the course of a
single episode like it happened at the
end of episode six so he was in the
wheelchair for most of episode 7 then by
episode 8 he had gotten his powers back
because that was the big crossover
episode with arrow so just give Nora
like an extra episode to not have her
powers but how funny of a reference
would it be to put her in a wheelchair
in one of the next episodes if not next
week's episode then maybe the episode
after that just another really cool
callback to what's going on between her
and reverse flash in the future because
that's the version that was wheeling
around during season 1 in the wheelchair
pretending that he couldn't walk
[Music]
but the way that this overarching
storyline ties back to the reverse-flash
story they set up during episode 10 is
you know can bad people turn good Amunet
blacks underling nor vac is back from
season four and he's looking at this
list of metahumans that they're trying
to save and says these are some pretty
bad people are you sure they're worth
saving because really this season now
isn't so much about bad humans versus
good metahumans like the flash trying to
take down evil people because cicada is
killing all metahumans indiscriminate of
whether they're rogues or whether
they're good people
berry has to make the call to treat the
bad ones just like the good like the
speech that he gave to noir if we don't
believe in them then who will like is a
very Aquaman movie type of twist where
he regrets what he did with black mantas
father and it ultimately led to the
creation of his own worst villain so
maybe berry helps some of these bad
metahumans and when it comes to the end
of the season in the big final battle
with cicada they help him out because he
helped them out and maybe even during
crisis on Infinite Earths with
reverse-flash so this kind of what's
going on this season berry Nora treating
everyone bad and good alike humanely so
that it pays off in the future so a big
question now though is whether or not
reverse-flash is being authentic when he
says he wants to turn over a new leaf
and if they're successful will
reverse-flash help them during crisis on
Infinite Earths when they're battling
the anti-monitor because of how smart he
is the way he understands the time-space
continuum and how he understands the
nature of the Speed Force on a
scientific level in a way that Barry
doesn't like there are a lot of things
that he can still teach Barry about the
Speed Force that will help them in their
fight against the anti-monitor still
open to debate whether or not
reverse-flash is pulling a long con and
whether or not he will eventually turn
over a new leaf they're very open about
the way they foreshadows stuff like that
in episodes so it'll be very clear later
this season so just keep your eyes
peeled for stuff like that Picabo is
back I think she's been in iron Heights
since the beginning of season 4 that was
the episode where Wally and Cisco were
working together because Barry was still
stuck in the Speed Force and they were
trying to bring him back so for a little
while while he was the main version of
the flash and their big adventure that
they opened the episode with was them
taking her down
dead-bang fellas
we gather a couple of the big things
going on in the DC Universe we're
supposed to get a new Shazam trailer I
don't know what day it is but I think
it's gonna happen sometime next week I
think that we're gonna wait till the
week after the spider-man far from home
trailer but the big rumor is is that
they're gonna reveal the seven deadly
sins we're gonna learn about how they
work in the film and we're gonna see
more of dr. sivana in his villain Mark
Strong has been hyping him up too so if
you haven't read the geoff johns new 52
Shazam storyline that's the one that
they based the movie on dr. sivana
features prominently into that so once
that new trailer drops I'll do my Easter
Egg video no worries leave all your
requests in the comments below also
reminder that arrow is back next week
and I think that most of the other DC TV
shows with the exception of legends of
tomorrow which I don't think is coming
back till April but that has not been
cancelled yet but I know there's a lot
of rumors about that don't worry if they
announce any news about arrowverse shows
being canceled I will totally make
videos about it
punisher is dropping at midnight tonight
as well i'll do a review video for that
in the next day so just look out for
that congratulations Tyler Andrews
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big flash video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here to rewatch all
my spider-man far from home trailer
videos and Easter eggs
and click here for all my Easter eggs
from last night's flash episode thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]